do lead to obesity,
and a number of other modern, kind of Westernized diseases.
The good news is that your microbiome can actually change.
Unlike your own genome,
it's a living, breathing thing,
and there's a broad front of research happening right now
to better understand how we can restore our microbiomes
when something goes wrong,
using diet,
using live microbes.
And in fact, one of the next steps for us
is collecting and preserving microbes from healthy people around the world
so that they can be kept as cultural assets for those groups
to potentially protect them as they adapt to modern society,
and to protect future generations
who are currently growing up to have increased risk of these diseases
with every generation.
I'm looking forward to a future
where we have the tools that we need to restore and replenish our microbiomes,
and in that world, the monkeys will live happier and healthier lives,
and so will we.
(Applause)